let's talk about walk away yes the
interesting thing about so I'll give a
quick I'm sure most people watching know
what the walk away campaign is this is a
guy I'm Brandon struck I think site
perhaps you pronounce it so I forgive me
Brandon I'm getting her name wrong but
he is a gay New York hair stylist
I hope I'm getting this right right he's
from New York right yeah and he's a and
that's that's like I mean not trying to
be rude but like very stereotypical like
gay dude right and then he made this
video where he was like and and I got a
say and I'm not trying to be mean but
he's a very you know his attitude his
demeanor was that of a regular you know
gay man right and explaining how the
left sure he knows that right yeah the
Democrat rying to be delicate you know
yeah especially cuz we're on YouTube
where you could ban in two seconds but
he made this video went viral I'm sure
most people have seen it and he talks
about how the Democratic Party has
embraced you know they were refused to
denounce the very least like an T for
violence this extreme rhetoric heart
extreme political correctness purity
testing circular firing squads and all
of this and that he was done with it and
so he decided to walk away and then it
quickly started gaining a ton of
traction I remember in this video
dropped and I saw it almost right away
at very few views and I was like aw this
interesting we'll see where this goes
and then also nine tons of people
messaging me saying like you got to
check out the walkaway campaign was
interesting to me is that it was led by
a gay man of all people you would think
who would want to lead the charge of
leaving the Democratic Party to the
Republican Party I'm told the
Republicans were the intolerant ones
were the bigots the Conservatives didn't
like the gay people a lot stuff
maybe super conservatives or old-school
conservative yet something changed Trump
Trump is the first president to actually
support gay marriage before becoming
president I did know that so I'm not
saying he's good on LGBT rights not you
know for a lot of reasons but Obama for
instance opposed it even in his first
term and so now there's been a lot of
progress that's been made I had someone
on the podcast was it last week when did
you come on that's two weeks ago two
weeks ago yeah any and he was so he was
a Democrat for a long time and he said
that when Cole
general issues came off the table like
gay marriage and pot legalization made
it really easy to make that switch so
I'm wondering I don't know I just wanted
to you know talk to you about the more
political aspects of it outside of the
cultural stuff with what does it mean
leaving the left what would be what
would be like something for you that
would make you consider voting for a
Republican if you if you supported some
of the things Trump did is there yeah
like what would stop you from voting for
Trump I would think is his stance on
women's rights that's that's what would
stop me if if there was because because
I haven't looked into his policies as
much as I'd be lying I'd be like I don't
look into his policies because it
stresses me the hell out of politics
dresses me out yeah oh yeah but now
you're now you but but now I'm getting
butt involved slowly I think this is
what happens it's kind of like a funnel
or like you know a toilet is a better
example you're you're on the outside of
these cultural issues that very much
lead straight into the political battle
it does so you as a lesbian who was
attacked and insulted and then called
all the worst names in the book what
section it's interesting it's a very
similar parallel to a bunch of other
culture war type issues where it's like
you know I don't you know when it comes
to race issues when it comes to feminism
identity and all this stuff they will
cast you out like a leper in two seconds
they'll say get out of our party and
then where do you go so I don't know
well let me ask you what do you think
about like Brandon walk away cuz Blair
White's involved in that I found it from
Blair and I I think it makes so much
sense to like go to the Republican Party
well just to walk away from the left I
don't know about going Republican cuz
again I don't really have much to say
about that just yet yeah I know but I
think I won heat when I saw that he was
doing that I said yeah that makes sense
so gay gay white men at this point are
the hated the most hated people in the
LGBT community and I get it but you met
you also mentioned we were talking about
this there was an article that said
black men are the white people of black
people
yes it's straight black men yeah the
white was it what is it what so non non
trans people not cisgender is like non
trans so cisgender straight black men
are the white people or the white people
of black people what what so okay no you
know what it means though you know it
means is that is that the most shocking
thing tans like where's party I'm sure
what they're saying I'm sure the people
watching or like I have no idea what
that means it means they're like the
privileged elite um yeah all right so so
let me try to ask you this way uh I ask
you how old you are
are you are you I'm 33 normally what I
say is why not what I'm talking to talk
about that no no you do but here's what
I usually say are you old enough to wear
if I ask your age you'll be offended yes
and then like millennial women are like
now well I mean maybe now that we're in
our 30s but so so we're basically saying
we're literally the same age yeah I grew
up at a time when the Republicans were
intolerant moral immoral immoral
authoritarian yeah and now I'm looking
at what's going on with a left a net and
it's it's definitely inverting at least
so I'm curious what your perspective is
you know I don't understand you don't
know a lot about policy so I want to put
you on the spot saying like who would
you vote for why what's like how do you
feel like yes yes but let me let me
qualify a little bit more because my
family owned a coffee shop on the north
side of Chicago for a couple years and
it was on North Halsted in the it was
it's Boys Town in Chicago absolutely
yeah they got the rain but they got
these big spear like pillar like like
things with Wayne bows on them and my
mom was very much like we need to fight
for these rights and it was the Liberals
on the left and the COS the Republican
religious right that were very much
opposed to it I grew up with that and so
there was a bit of hesitation when I
started seeing a lot of this you know
years and years ago when I was like I
don't believe it I don't buy it and it
was kind of strange to see of all people
like someone like Brendan struck a gay
man being like putting out a manga hat
and being like Republicans so I'm
curious like and he's around our age -
probably yes I don't know how you feel
like it's like it's like a mirror
universe like bizarro world
I don't know I don't know I saw it
coming yes not coming yeah because I I
think you tubers and and people on
Twitter see it quicker than anybody else
because we see we see the little whoa I
think a little quiet passive-aggressive
jabs here and there and we're like
that's weird that they would say that
and then it catches on and more people
start talking like that and then I'm
like okay so was there you how long have
been on YouTube ten years so what I know
that there was a period where like lefty
YouTube was really really big I would
say that was the last five years but the
past two of those five it's been
decreasing and now like now like Blair
White has come yeah thank God thank God
why I think I think you know people
don't sit i think people got sick of the
entitlement they got sick of things that
arguments that don't make sense
they're not even arguments because they
don't make sense they're just telling
people to shut up and calling them Nate
was half the time yeah at least in my
case I noticed you know man 2013-14
there were some big feminist youtubers
who are getting hundreds of thousands of
views today they get nothing and it's
and it's the more moderate to right-wing
voices that are getting tons of traffic
I think that should show you that walk
away is legitimate it definitely is
they tried claiming that it was Russian
BOTS it was fake it was astroturf hang
no one's away yeah yeah yeah no one no
one's really leaving the left and I look
on YouTube no right so what well I mean
take you a wild in it
I feel like it's been happening like I
said for the last two years though to
only slowly I haven't really made any
content with super progressive
progressive people in the last two years
now I used to and then I noticed that
once I started speaking my truth these
people would slowly unfollow me they
didn't want it they didn't want to be
associated with me and I was like I saw
the shift and I was like okay well if
they're not gonna talk about it I'm
gonna have to be the martyr again that's
my story
how much of this do you think is people
who are scared to speak up cuz will be
canceled 75% of it or do you think
they're people who just literally have
no principles and are like I don't know
whatever the mob says I'll do those are
the young kids that just go with
with the flow but people people are its
nest they just don't know I mean some of
them are little I think some of them are
little punks but I think most of the
kids just want to belong and they don't
know and and and you know the
progressive world your valid your valid
every one salad except you except a
lesbian we actually the interesting
thing is like they hate lesbians they do
why though I don't know because I don't
know because we have they hate women who
like women that have a lot to say I
guess yeah I really did I really think
that that's that's part of it yeah do
you think these kids will grow out of it
or anything they'll get worse I think
they need therapy we're not gonna get it
I like no because everybody salad but
look I think I'm gonna get worse I'll
tell you one thing there are a very
small subset of people vocal small
people publicly and privately that used
to hate me
and then they grew up and realized that
the other people that they were
idolizing we're actually like sociopaths
like actually sociopaths and horrible
people they're they're they're us take
some the truth comes out like I'm not
I'm not worried about it it just might
take some time and I get some backlash
and I grow from it yeah yeah you know
what man I'm very much if tomorrow
everyone's opinions went like super hard
in one direction and I was told by
literally everyone I knew Tim you have
to change your opinions now or will ban
you from YouTube I'd be like bring it on
I don't care IIIi have been begging for
a purge so I can just go fishing to
relieve all of this lunacy behind no III
just want a cabin in the woods and I
want to meet my wife and have 80 cats 80
cats
I haven't banned all this come on take
my van down by the river because these
people are so nice to American some it's
it's sometimes holy fish it's exhausting
dealing with like how crazy these people
are mentally exhausted I honestly have
to I have well I don't know well I have
I have a few friends it's too late I
think you said it doesn't matter we
could just
I have a few friends like that I talked
to that that you know Bach angels one of
them yeah a few friends that have to
like bring me back down to earth and be
like you are not the crazy one because I
I see so much crazy I and there's so
much of it and because people that
aren't speaking up are the ones that are
like on my side but they're not talking
so I only see the negative I have to
you're not the crazy one I know I have
to have my friends be like it's okay
there's there's there's so much proof in
little grains of sand like you know the
saying how many grains can make a heap
so I use analogy for everything so
people are watching on I roll here goes
to him again with the breath but there's
a saying how many grains of sand until
you have a heap of sand because one
grain isn't two grains isn't so each
little grain is evidence that proves it
but eventually you stack it up and the
proof is we're not the crazy ones we're
not one example is gal putting out a
poll today showing that people are less
likely to identify as a Democrat more
likely to identify as a Republican Dave
Chappelle's comedy special Dave
Chappelle made foot made it made in a
Chinese man face stereotype joke he made
a joke about his a trans woman someone
who's actually his friend who then you
know wanted to say that they appreciate
accident normalized you know them and
who they were but you look at look at
the most popular podcast in the world
Joe Rogan and Joe Rogan gets mad about
some you know about the trans issues and
stuff like this so if you if you even
have the most popular podcast if you can
have the data even coming out if you can
have a gay hairdresser launch this
campaign this walk away campaign with
hundreds of thousands of followers the
media will lie they'll kick and scream
the whole way saying it's it's fake news
it's Russian bots it's astroturf thing
and then it's like dude look at YouTube
how many how many how many views on
these feminist channels nothing how many
views on moderate to conservative the
conservatives are going huge no like
we're both liberals this is the crazy
thing to me man I hate it
I'm so mad cuz that cuz look like
eventually you have people I'm sure in
the comments section right now flying
like crazy saying Tim your only option
is of a Republican and I got it I got
I'll be the first to admit there's some
truth there I'm not gonna say they're
completely right just yet cuz I have I
have I have a weird strategy for like
what I think works how I go about things
but we really are getting to a point
where it's like the average person like
us will have more in common with a
Republican than anyone on the left
because you look at like the debate
stage and there I don't know if you saw
this Elizabeth Warren you know about
Warren's campaigning all that stuff I'm
sure she said she went oh she has her
pronouns in their bio she there you go
are you familiar with zoo bees razor is
its ooby's razor you know zoo bees razor
is I'm gonna you know it so basically
it's if someone has the pronouns in
their bio you can basically discount
anything they say so to put it in like
trying to make it more of a academic
it's like any any any profile how do you
say that you can disregard the opinions
of anyone who puts pronouns in their
profile it's like that
so Elizabeth Warren said she would only
approve a Secretary of Education if a
trans miner approved and interviewed and
approved of the cabinet member so
Elizabeth Warren's a minor yes so Bill
Maher talked about this and he says
forget the trans part why would you give
a high-schooler veto power on a cabinet
pick that's how insane they've gone and
of course she tanks in the polls after
saying these stuff because regular
people are like they're insane but
here's the thing
regular me liberal minded people like
you and me we're rare the liberal many
people who are willing to stand up and
speak about it
few and far between but they have no
problem just going to check in the box
for the Republicans right yeah I think
because most people don't want to be
leaders in the fight liberal like
old-school liberals people who are
Democrat six years ago are saying
themselves I know what will happen if I
come out and say these things I quit so
they won't say anything they won't say
any that there's literally every the
funny part of it is the youtubers that
aren't saying anything their views are
dropping - yep yeah but the people that
are starting to speak up like me and
that's not why I started speaking up I
started speaking because I have morals
yeah principles I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna flounder because people throwing
hate at me yeah you know in a weird way
I feel like I feel like I'm one of the
first lesbians that started
talking you know that started yelling
back so to speak at this you know the
route activists and I think I'm proud of
myself for that and then and then I
luckily at the same time it just so
happened that people like Blair and
Calvin and Ryan yeah a few friends of
mine London you know people started
speaking up as well and that gives more
lead to people to feel like they could
speak up I was reading about gamergate
stuff and I was reading from a guy who
was not super political saying that he
used to support these left-wing causes
because they were predicated on like
legitimate things like better
representation for women and video games
and stuff but then quickly saw that they
were essentially just milking money out
of people the the anger never stopped
they were always angry about something
no matter what anyone did they always
said it was wrong and problematic every
time they gained some kind of success
they still claim they were victims and
eventually said I don't have anything do
with this what's interesting about that
is the walkaway idea is not just like
it's like okay I feel like Brandon kind
of identified something in a political
space but culturally everything about
the left is either people are choosing
to walk walk away or they're being
forced to walk away but it affects
YouTube
it affects Twitter it's political in the
voting sense it's on TV and now you can
see that the right panels right lesbians
so there were three lesbians three sis
lesbians and because they got so much
hate they added a trans woman and a
non-binary person to a lesbian like a
lesbian Pat liked it what it was like
it's okay in my opinion yes it's good to
be intersectional but it's also okay to
not always be intersectional like
lesbians have different opinions
different experiences than a trans woman
who's a lesbian
identifies that way might have but this
is the problem with intersectionality is
that there's always like you can
intersect forever on every different
thing and so you end up with I think I
think the trans issue of women in sports
is that is the best example of where
these laws fall apart in that you have a
law that says you can't discriminate
based on gender identity and sex
so then allowing trans women to compete
in female sports is sex BAE
discrimination but not along them is
gender identity basis based
discrimination so you no matter what you
do the law guarantees you are
discriminating there's no way there's no
way to do this effectively either
discriminate or down oh no I'm sorry no
matter what you do you'll discriminate
so there's no way that like the law has
become completely it's it's an Ouroboros
it's it's that it's that snake eating
its tail it just ends with its own
destruction and and and I think I mean I
I would like to think that the people
creating these laws meant well you know
they're trying to make it better for
everybody I think it's just not being
you think they're just trying to shut
everybody up no I think they're like
what gets me but what's you know what's
any votes okay so as long as people like
us like I don't mean like us in the
sense we do speak up we're speaking up
now yeah but so many like men the people
who used to watch The Daily Show when
John Stehr was on they refuse to speak I
get angry about this I'm like if you
just started putting up a fuss like
people who go to work and they're like
oh I better not say anything I was my
job to say something the amount of
emails I never get tweets
I'll get direct messages on Instagram
emails Facebook messages that I get
every day with mostly women if not all
women and maybe like one gay guy or so
and and most of them are lesbians of
course saying that you know I I agree
with everything you say I had this
experience you know I was called
transphobic or I was called biphobic or
whatever I was killed who the hell knows
at this point they've been called
something or they didn't agree with
something that was happening and they
couldn't say anything because they work
for a not-for-profit and they don't want
to lose their job well they work for
some you know woke company and they
can't say it you know it's it's created
it's created like a trap for themselves
you can't get out of yeah like over I
remember you know you basically have
during Pride Month every single brand
will turn their logo to a rainbow yeah
and now it's come to a point where you
have these bullies who control that
space kicking even you out of it and so
these businesses look man if an actual
member of that community can't speak up
and say hey here's what how I feel what
do you think Oreo cookies gonna be able
to do about it and how they better bend
the knee fast cuz they got nothing to
stand
right these bullies are gonna come for
him they're gonna destroy your brand and
you know what you deserve it
actually yeah yeah I'll mention this too
because you were mentioning that support
for gay rights is down the rate of LGBT
acceptance is is it's in decline that's
and I get it because I don't even like
half of the people that are associating
with us that are that are claiming to be
part of our community like at this point
anybody can be queer anybody anybody can
be non-binary like there's not even set
definitions of it anymore
I don't want to name these people
because they don't deserve the attention
that they so crave but like a certain
individual who went into a one's
bathroom and start taking pictures in
the mirror of like little girls and
stuff yeah sending horrifying messages
the examples of the worst of the worst
and the problem is not so I I don't I
don't think would be fair to say that
most people on the Left would actually
agree with these lunatics they wouldn't
agree with the lunatics that they won't
tell you well they don't agree with with
the person abusing that privilege that
right that you know the law but they
don't say anything but but they it's the
logic it's the how do you say it's the
logic not the logic behind it but they
want to believe that people basically
what is from times I if you have a if
you have a terrible terribly worded law
you know or something that's so so
generalized that you can't define it you
know like what a woman is okay it's just
somebody who identifies and is that and
it's self ID then you're gonna have
predators like right don't that doesn't
position that doesn't mean that trans
women are necessarily going to be these
predators that's not what this means it
means that people that are predators in
general are gonna take advantage of it
well so what ends up happening is what
I've seen is that many of the
high-profile leftists will say things
like oh I'm not gonna call this person
out because they don't represent us and
that's an unfair low blow and then what
ends up happening is regular people see
this unchecked lunatic yep taking
advantage of the space and these
privileges and you know these these
rights and then a community that just
you know snubs their nose and looks away
and says you know they're under the
thing whatever I'm not gonna
anything it's not fair so then the
average person sees that craziness and
says I don't like this and then it
results in acceptance going down that's
exactly what happens that's why Blair
White has that that series on her
channel I believe where she's she's
calling out the the ridiculousness
coming out of the LGBTQ community the
same woodrose have dawn
she has her series called trans stupid
trance trance - how do you not get
banned for me I don't know well she's
trans so maybe she gets a pass right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we're live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. and if
you want to catch the full recorded
podcast which doesn't appear in these
clips make sure you join by clicking the
button down below become a member and
then go to the community tab of this
YouTube channel and you can see all of
our full episodes don't forget to Like
share and subscribe if you want to get
more clips like this thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all in the next
show
you